we are subverting illegitimate authority
wikileaks released 76 000 classified
field reports of u.s operations in
afghanistan he has done a lot of harm to
the united states of america and he
should pay for that i hope he rocked in
hell starting with that yeah wikileaks
walks like a hostile intelligence
service and talks like a hostile
intelligence service publish true
information that is otherwise unsavable
joe biden said julian assange as a
high-tech terrorist you cannot trust a
government to implement the policies
that it says it is implementing he has
to answer for what he has done and so we
must provide the underlying tools
many establishment journalists in the
u.s consider julian assange to be a
criminal whose work doesn't fit in the
same category as their own no journalism
here what we have is an act of espionage
the wholesale dumping of wikileaks
actually isn't journalism if you help in
the stealing of classified material
nothing about the first amendment is
going to insulate you from charges that
you stole regardless of whether or not
you publish it i mean you learn that day
one in news business school in april
2019 police dragged the wikileaks
founder out of the ecuadorian embassy
where he lived for seven years after the
u.s government indicted him for
allegedly helping chelsea manning access
government databases the new york times
editorial board applauded the move
writing that it could help draw a sharp
line between legitimate journalism and
dangerous cyber crime and said that the
trump administration has begun well by
charging mr assange with an indisputable
crime julian assange is not a free press
hero the washington post editorial board
opined and he is long overdue for
personal accountability many in the
media revile assange and wikileaks for
publishing the dnc and clinton campaign
chairman john podesta's leaked emails
before the 2016 election he hacked into
the democrats computers and that's why
trump won basically timing it
right before the debate we have to
acknowledge how political wikileaks and
julian are being here the disdain is
mutual with assange regularly describing
the corporate press as complicit in
hiding vital information from the public
history is shaped and distorted
by
the media it is
our single greatest impediment
to advancement then in may 2019 the us
government unsealed a second set of
charges against assange that if they
were to result in a conviction could set
a dangerous legal precedent that would
put all investigative journalists who
expose state secrets at risk of going to
prison whether or not the media
considers assange one of their own his
fate could have a profound impact on the
future of their profession
the government is now charging assange
with violating the espionage act of 1917
by publishing the information leaked by
chelsea manning if convicted he could
face up to 175 years in prison edward
snowden a former government contractor
has also been charged under the
espionage act for leaking information to
the media which is how it's more
commonly used what's different about the
saunders case is that the government is
claiming an individual unaffiliated with
the government is guilty of a criminal
violation for seeking out and publishing
classified information which is exactly
what journalists do on a routine basis
the trump administration today just put
every journalistic institution in this
country on julian assange's side of the
ledger which i know is unimaginable
even many of his biggest media critics
are concerned by the additional charges
really anybody who is concerned about
press freedom should
be extremely concerned
about the prosecution of julian assange
freedom of the press foundation
co-founder trevor tim who testified in
assange's uk extradition hearing says
that assange's conviction under the
espionage act would set a precedent that
could endanger any journalist publishing
leaked information about the us
government maybe journalists don't like
julian assange or they have criticized
many of his actions over the years
that's all well and good but what really
matters is the acts for which the
justice department is trying to
criminalize here bob woodward for the
past 40 years has made his entire career
off writing books on various
administrations national security
policies he had a book called obama's
wars for example that came out in 2010
it is hundreds of pages of highly
classified information basically the
most sensitive information that you
could possibly imagine at a far higher
classification level than anything
wikileaks published the investigation
that made bob woodward the most famous
journalist in the united states that led
to the resignation of richard nixon bob
woodward and his partner carl bernstein
engaged in what the government is
calling a conspiracy in the assange case
they were going to grand jurors houses
for example and trying to convince them
to hand over information that it would
be illegal for the grand juror to hand
over this precedent was around during
the richard nixon era it's possible that
woodward and bernstein would have been
stopped far before watergate and deep
throat became household names richard
nixon may never have had to resign they
quite possibly could have gone to jail i
shall resign the presidency effective at
noon tomorrow
the government claims that wikileaks
crossed a legal line by posting a list
of most wanted classified documents and
providing the encrypted dropbox that
manning would use to submit the iraq and
afghanistan war logs but tim says this
too is standard journalistic practice
freedom of the press foundation the
organization i run we have a software
project called secure draw and secure
drop is essentially an open source
version of a whistleblower submission
system something that wikileaks had a
hand in pioneering back in the early
2000s and 2010s journalists at major
newspapers around the country and around
the world are constantly asking sources
to leak them information of course they
are and they're increasingly doing this
in the internet age in a very public way
but when the new york times launched
their secure drop they took out a
full-page ad in their own paper i wrote
a piece in the guardian saying that
somebody should leave the torture report
back in 2014 get if the government
wasn't going to release it in full
because it contained evidence of illegal
and unconstitutional acts so this is a
common tactic by reporters by newspapers
by common citizens everywhere and
thankfully at least for now it's covered
under the first amendment and i'm
worried if this case goes forward
that
it wouldn't be
one of the key accusations in the case
against assange is that he violated the
computer fraud and abuse act by
allegedly offering to help chelsea
manning crack a password to a government
database in an effort to cover her
tracks on this count many journalists
have sided squarely with the government
the government seems to be hanging their
hat on this single quite weak charge
which relates to a 30-second
conversation between julian assange and
chelsea manning nothing ever came of it
i think this one charge is potentially a
sideshow trying to convince the judge
that assange is some sort of hacker and
and
that this doesn't relate to journalism
while recognizing that assange's case is
vital to the cause of press freedoms
many journalists have treated him with
disdain often portraying his years-long
confinement in the ecuadorian embassy as
self-imposed a ploy to dodge sex crime
charges in sweden which were dropped in
november 2019 assange defended himself
by claiming he was seeking asylum from
extradition to the u.s where he would be
indicted on charges that would seek to
deny him first amendment protections a
prediction that's been borne out the
years of confinement have taken a toll
on his mental and physical health in
2018 doctors determined that assange's
condition was deteriorating after years
of confinement and asked that he be
allowed safe passage to a hospital that
request was denied in 2019 the un
special rapporteur on torture nils
melzner described the conditions assange
has been subjected to as psychological
torture a decade ago assange was well
regarded in establishment circles
the standing ovation he received at this
2010 ted talk is inconceivable today
assange created wikileaks in 2006 and
leaked documents about the inner
workings of guantanamo bay vice
presidential candidates sarah palin's
emails and bank fraud in iceland the
organization first grabbed widespread
public attention with this
[Music]
video wikileaks would title collateral
murder showed footage from a us army
apache helicopter of soldiers gunning
down more than a dozen people in baghdad
who weren't engaged in active combat
including two reuters reporters the
video generated international press and
controversy assange said his intention
was to expose the casual carnage and
destruction happening in the course of
the u.s war in iraq it was
another day at the office how routine it
was a whole street covered with bodies
the reaction to that
the iraq war logs which followed was the
largest military leak in history
revealing that more than 15 000 civilian
deaths hadn't been publicly reported and
it exposed the fact that the u.s
military had ignored reports of torture
rape and murder by iraqi authorities and
soldiers
15 000 people whose deaths
were recorded by the us military but
were completely unknown to the rest of
the world that's a very significant
thing and compare that to the 3 000
people who died in 9 11 and imagine the
significance
then in november 2010 there was a leak
of more than 3 million u.s diplomatic
cables revealing corruption among
various arab governments which helped
inspire the tunisian revolution that
began the arab spring
wikileaks also released thousands of
pages of both cia and russian state
surveillance techniques exposed saudi
support for isis and undisclosed u.s
training of soldiers in yemen and helped
provide edward snowden safe passage out
of hong kong assange says his guiding
principle has been to grant regular
citizens access to the information
powerful governments corporations and
media gatekeepers wanted nobody to see
someone's right to speak and someone's
right to know produce a right to
communicate and so that is the grounding
structure
for
all that we treasure
about civilized life but the 2016
leagues damaging to the hillary clinton
campaign and democratic party found him
both new allies on the right you have
done a lot of good in what you have
exposed about how corrupt dishonest and
phony our government is wikileaks i love
wikileaks and critics on the left comes
at the mall report if we get a good look
at it next week and it's not too heavily
redacted we get a look at it it shows
that wikileaks
assange himself worked with the russians
to put out their attacks on the
democratic candidate hillary clinton but
assange who once said he viewed the
choice between clinton and trump as a
choice between cholera and gonorrhea and
who denies any connection to the russian
government maintains that his commitment
is to bringing to light true information
regardless of which political regime it
might damage we believe that the best
type of government comes from
a government that is scrutinized by the
people
when they have true information about
how government and major corporations
other power actors in society actually
behave tim says wikileaks early work
which went a long way towards revealing
the nature of 21st century american
warfare and surveillance and exposing
corrupt authoritarian governments is
what even those who dislike assange
should remember as he faces life in
prison much like julian assange himself
the legacy of wikileaks is complicated
they
did a lot of good for the world
especially in their early days when they
were releasing all sorts of really
important stories and really important
investigations i think people kind of
forget because their mind is clouded by
2016 the ability of news organizations
to run secure submission systems
prioritizing digital security this was
kind of a thing in 2010 that nobody had
even thought of and now everybody's
doing it the ability to create these
large coalitions of news organizations
who are going over huge data sets we can
look to investigations like the panama
papers for example where there's a whole
bunch of news organizations working
together this was not something that was
happening very often before wikileaks
partnered with the new york times the
guardian and many other papers their
legacy is certainly mixed but there's a
lot of good things a lot of lasting
things that have actually come out of
how wikileaks operated
[Music]
assange remains in a london prison
confined to his cell for 23 hours a day
according to wikileaks editor-in-chief
kristin hrafson he's awaiting a ruling
from the british extradition court which
is scheduled for january 4th government
whistleblowers such as edward snowden
daniel ellsberg john carracao and
william binney along with more than 7
600 co-signers to an open letter have
called for president trump to drop all
charges throughout his career however
assange has been cynical about the
notion that the democratic and judicial
process can truly constrain government
power and protect individual rights the
citizens of the world need to take
matters into their own hands and protect
themselves using encryption and other
freedom preserving tools slowly we will
end up into a global totalitarian
surveillance society perhaps they will
just be the last free living people
those people who understand how to use
this cryptography to defend against this
complete total surveillance
[Music]
you